こんにちははじめしおですえ先日ですね
ついについに本当に前のこのうつとお別れ
という動画を出させていただきましたが
悲しいもんですね4億円のうちに引っ越し
てから結構月日は立っているものの
やっぱりこのうで過ごした時間とか日々
ってのはYouTubeがバーって伸びて
た時期をここで過ごしたのですごいなんか
思い出深い場所なのでちょっと寂しい思い
と切ない思いがありながらまかなりもの
多かったですよ俺だけじゃなくてはめし
たちの畑で買ったものとかめっちゃ
たくさんありましたすごい日数かけて物を
全部運んであの引っ越し完了して空きに
することができたんですけれどもあのどう
しても運べないものが1個だけありまして
ちょっととりあえず見ますとりあえず見
ましょうか見ないと始まんないもんなはい
ガレージに入ったんですけれども
あのこれ
[音楽]
です皆さん覚えてますでしょうか結構昔に
買ったんですけれどもこれいつ動画にもし
ました
350万円のゲーミングチェア
ですあの運び方が分からん運び方がわから
ないしあの分解の仕方も分からないので
分解したとしてもまた組み立てられる自信
がなくてあの未だにこのかず
アミューズメントパーク4億円のちの前の
お家ハップに未だに置いてありますいつ
買ったっけ結構昔なんだよなちょうど3年
前だ3年前に買ったんですけどこの
ゲーミングチェアマジで史上最強に高い
ゲーミングチェアちょっと見てみましょう
か移動とかは割といけるんですよなんか
あと動くんでかなり動かしやすい一応ねま
ゲーミングチアてだけで移動はできるん
ですよあの1年ぶりぐらいに見たので
ちょっとどんなのだったかなんかあんまり
覚えてないのでちょっと1回見てみようと
思い
ますはいでは見ていきたいと思います
なんかこの鉄の部分とか錆びてはいないの
でかなりあの状態はいいと思います
ちょっと埃とか乗ってるんですけどもこれ
が実際のチェアですねいい椅子プレデター
でこうやってなんか伸びてて伸びた先に
えっとディスプレイが3つついていますで
稼動式のなんか手置ける場所とドリンク
ホルダーでなんかUSBがバーンてあっ
たりとか何がすごいやっぱ見た目だよ
ねめっちゃかっけはいこんなかっこいい
350前のゲーミングチアなんですけれど
もあの
その買ってから4回しか使ってませんすい
ませんあの4回しか使ってないのであの
ほぼ新品です日は3年ほど経ってて結構
時間は経ってるんでなんかそのほりとかと
いうのありますけどもほぼ使ってません
買ったままの状態ですほぼ4回しか使って
ませんかなり質はいいですで今回これを
どうしようかと言いますと4億円のおちも
ね結構物が多くなってきて運べない持って
でけなかったんでですよかつ分解の仕方も
分からないそして僕配信用のPC
ディスプレイとかゲーミングスペース
ゲームする場所がもう完璧にできちゃっ
てるの
で使わないんですね350万円のこれ使わ
なくなっちゃいました350万円の
ゲーミングチェアでなんかパソコン
ゲーミングPCもついてたんですけども
それはまだ使ってるんですよPC抜きの
本当にゲーミングチアだけが今残ってるん
ですけども
これ
オークションに出し
ますオークション行き決定ですこれえこの
350万円のゲーミングジアオークション
出しますなんか俺使わないのよ使わないし
買う時にお話聞いた時にめっちゃレアでも
全然ないみたいなめっちゃ希少価値高いの
でだったらねなんかゲーム付きの人とか
ガチのプロゲーマーとかプロゲーマー
目指してる人とかめっちゃゲーム好きとか
こういう金未来な椅子がお家に欲しいって
いう人いると思うんですよきっとそういう
方の方がはきっと僕が持ってるより使える
と思うのでこの350万円のゲーミング
チェアオークションで売ることにしました
はい0円で0円で売りますよ0円0円0円
はいこちらのゲーミングチェア0円から
オークションで出品させてていただきます
はいYahooオークションで0円で出品
させていただきますで買いたい人が
少なければワンチャンこれ1円とか2円で
買えます俺も値段は気にしてないのではい
から売らせていただきますよこれなんか昔
ねトレーニングジムのセト全部売ったこと
あるんですけどもそれも結構な値段行って
て今回トレーニングルームよりねなんか
ゲームで流行ってるしディスプレイとかも
これAさんめっちゃいいやつでしょ3画面
ついてますよ3画面であのAPEXとかし
ていただきたいとりあえずねきっと
ゲーマーの方だったらちょっと欲しいって
人が多いなとそして350万円みたいな
バカ桁ネたでは売りません0円からの
スタートでこちらオクションに出させて
いただきますただし条件がありますあのね
運べないんですよ分解してね復帰も多分
できないと思うので落札していただける方
の条件としまして
あの持っていっていただけると持っていっ
ていただけるとという条件ですもちろん
持っていき方色々あると思います自ら足を
運んでいただいてあの直接対応いたします
あの会いますよなんか直その手渡してこれ
をなんかトラックとかで持っていただいて
もいいですし者が自分でこれをなんか業者
に運んでいただいてもいいんですけども
とりあえずあの自分の力で持ってって
いただけるととてもありがたいというで
それだけがちょっと条件です運べないわけ
じゃないんですけど運ぶのが大変なので僕
はもうお家に持っていかない決心をした
ものですそこはちょっとあのご自身でま
業者に頼めるばできると思うんですけども
ブラックとか何かの手段でご自宅に持っ
てっていただける方という条件で出品させ
ていただきますまそもそもこんなこと言っ
てても本当にこれ動くかどうか分からない
のでちょっと1回動かしてみますねこれで
壊れてたらもう塗り物じゃないから細かい
傷とか状態はぜひあのYahoo
オークションの方で確認してください
決してあのいい状態とは言えないでも
ちゃんと掃除したら絶対綺麗なのよ俺4回
しか乗ってないからじゃあちょっと動作
確認させていただきますそもそもこれが
動くかどうかって話だよ
なこれでゲームできるも最高
よ電源どこだっけやばい乗らなすぎて全部
忘れちゃった思い出した多分ここら辺これ
がボタンになってるんだはいお来た来たあ
はいはいこれですこれですこれこれこれ
これです
[音楽]
よかっこよくないこれですこれ思い出した
このかっこよさえ売りたくなくなってき
ちゃっためっちゃかっこいいこれでゲーム
できるのよはい座ってる目線としてはここ
にあのこうキーボードとかパッドとかね
マウスとか置いて画面がこういう感じで3
つ映ってますえやばいでしょこれでこれ
光るのよ確かここにボタンあるんですけど
もこれ押すとなと光りますこの上が暗い
ところだとめっちゃ多分光るんだろうなで
色々あってこれ押すとあれなんか色々
ボタンで操作できるのよねこれをすると
ペダルが多分上がるのよここの足のほら
ほらほら自分の好きな体勢でゲームを
遊べるという仕組みになってます新幹線
みたいあ僕です便利だなすごいよこれ押す
とあ椅子があすごいすごいすごい背もたれ
背もたれあすごいわあこれ結構すごいよ
こういう感じでめっちゃリクライニングで
ゲームでき
ますはいこれを戻しアームも移動自由と
[音楽]
すごいどうです皆さんこれめっちゃぽく
ないですかこれね本当にねなんかPC
ゲームとかでガチになりたい方は本当に
いいと思うんですよ3画面あるんですよ
どうやって使うの一応動作確認したんです
けども問題なく動くことは確認できました
ちょっとまた不具合とかあったらねあの
ヤフオのところでちゃんと書かせて
いただくのでぜひあの購入ご希望されてる
方はチェックしておいてください俺マジで
テンション上がんのよ普通にそうなんで俺
こんな使わなかったっていうと俺さゲーム
配信とかで自分ずかさグリーンバッこう
いうしっかりしたゲーミングチアに座っ
ちゃうと背景緑にできないから合成で抜け
ないんですよだからちょっと使う機会が
なかったなっていう感じなんですけども
なんか本当ゲーム集中したい方とかは俺が
ねもし自分の顔映さない配信者とかゲーム
実況者だったら絶対これは使ってました
かっこよすぎですねこれはもういや
すげえ映画3本一気見したいね3画面で
はいこういう感じの350万円で買いまし
た史上最強のゲーミングチアいかが
でしょうかモニターミこれ本当どうやって
使うんだろうなまけどきっとプロゲーマー
とか使うんでしょうねモニター3つではい
こちらですねYahooオークションの方
で出品させていただいております多分ね
この動画出た頃からスタートしてて
ちょっとその締め切りの日とかはあの約束
の方で確認していただけると助かりますが
本当ね4回しか乗ってないので3年間の
汚れとかはあるけどもうばっちり動きます
し色々ね拭けば全然綺麗だと思います
決していい状態とは言えないですけども
問題なく使える状態で出品させていただき
ますなんせかっこいいな是非とも興味ある
方は動画の概要欄にYahooオのURL
あるのでそっから見てみてください値段の
変動がどうなってくかとかもちょっと
楽しみですねま僕は2円でも売りますけど
ねというわけで皆様350万円の
ゲーミングチア購入お待ちしております
じゃあ
[音楽]
な
お